E aí
[Música]
hoje eu vou falar enquanto docentes aí
investigadora no meu caso em particular
enquanto biólogo a trabalho em
bioquímica SMA Matriz são as minhas
disciplinas numa acho que elas nesse não
não acho que elas limitam mas enquadram
muito do meu pensamento não há maneira
de fugir a Isto é importante que nem
sequer vou tentar nós quando fazemos
coisas deste gênero não falamos todo
aquilo que nós sabemos falamos sobretudo
daquilo que nós somos e portanto parte
do que vou dizer é que o que eu sou quer
fundo aquilo que é na até mais fácil
para para comunicar ao longo do meu
percurso de muitas vezes zangada tive
muitas vezes parado não quer dizer que
não estás agora já estão bocadinho
controla um carro melhor isto aí como
toda a gente achava as vezes que o mundo
estava contribui que tinha Sorte sorte o
que eu tinha azar e no fundo até até que
a certa altura percebi que estão aqui
aqui eu achava que era o protagonista
é um filme e com os outros todos
carnaval a minha volta era um ator
secundário aqui onde nós temos também
receber É Que Nós também somos atores
secundários na vida das outras pessoas
que estão o que conosco interagem e
portanto no mundo não está
necessariamente só ficava e nós isso não
é fácil lá Não é fácil a pessoa perceber
isto Aliás o meu percurso começou no
ensino superior começou um pouco antes a
no ensino de um próprio ensino
secundário quando se dica e ative para
biologia não para medicina por exemplo a
mas logo no ensino universitário tive um
choque presunto muitos de vós também
poderão ter tido quando assistiam a
alguma professora a minha que estava a
projetar na slides na um eclipse mas
depois que limitava a ler um classista
E eu achava aquilo enfim não só
monóculos mas completamente inútil e
lembra-me de falar com ela aí dizer é
para se calhar a soltura podia arranjar
outras estratégias outra maneira dar as
aulas ela ficou um queria aborrecida
comigo confia confesso mas até ouviu o
que eu disse e na aula a seguir no bolo
mas mudou de uma maneira que não foi
assim super o teu continuo a ler os
slides mas Lia muito mais devagar como
se o problema fosse que eu achasse que
ela estava a ler muito depressa e por
isso é que eu não estava a perceber não
que estava tudo lá escrito ela estava a
ler o que ela está vamos fazer não
precisava ter que dar lá para nada já
outro professor a tocava a música
clássica nas aulas e usava aquilo para
me explicar a estrutura das proteínas
usava as fugas de barra para explicar as
estruturas repetitivas no colagénio foi
uma
é super fascinante nunca tinha tal tinha
visto se conta o resto da vida ainda
hoje me lembro lembro disso aeroporto
Vitória madeira e para ter eu percebi
que nós podemos fazer a diferença
podemos fazer coisas diferentes um
bocadinho diferentes no ensino podíamos
a tentarem levar qualquer coisa mas que
há alguns casos no vale muito a pena é
porque não havia pessoas que se
cadastraram mais sensíveis a isso do que
outro e portanto tínhamos era que nos
adaptar às diferentes circunstâncias
é mas antes uma pessoa poderá começar
tentar mudar as circunstâncias tem que
se identificar tanto crescer
profissionalmente e toda o primeiro tive
que fica fazer um percurso que mostrasse
o que é que era ser um biólogo o que é
que era ser um professor o que é que era
ser um cientista e ser de maneira a que
as pessoas me reconhecem como tal o
reconhecessem qualidades mostrassem
editou-se via trabalhar dentro da caixa
se quiser antes da gente conseguir sair
da Caixa temos de saber onde é que tá a
caixa ok e temos que perceber eu estou a
sair da caixa de porque eu quero fazer
coisas diferentes não porque eu não
saiba trabalhar dentro da caixa mas só
que a caixa só não me dá tudo o que eu
acho que uma pessoa pode pode pode ser
importante eu tive que trabalhar um
carro para que a minha inconformidade o
meu desespero fossem úteis e muito
viagem também já agora fosse mais lutas
possíveis a isto faz parte não se
aborreçam se estejam acham que estão
conformados
é uma questão a questão ao de ser
demasiado aquele que perdem de voz que
estão encaixar demasiado numa
determinada estruturas isto faz parte
faz parte da nossa aprendizagem mas
depois temos a que pedir Ser Capaz de
sair dessas caixas embora temos que
saber como é que elas funcionam e tanto
tempo que temos que ser assim que
possível E por que a escola a velocidade
toda a escola deve ser vista como
formadora de cidadãos ativos produtivos
empreendedores mas também solidários e
Livres mas ao introduziam ao
interagirmos com com a sociedade que
também temos o corremos o risco de a
escola ser um instrumento para produzir
exatamente o mesmo tipo pessoas e o
mesmo tipo de opiniões e o mesmo tipo de
problemas já existem essas também não
podemos produzir pessoas amor faz
cidadãos perpetuum vieses pensar
o fundo como se fossem verdades
absolutas e raramente são e sobretudo
não podemos no caso da Universidade que
ela me viu que idade grandiloquente a
dosar palavras cara sepiplus e rituais
que são muito lutas mas não podemos
deixar que isso nos limite e por isso
nos coroa porque as vezes ficamos só
rituais isso é que não pode ser quando
eu comecei a dar aulas achava que a
matéria e eu dava e os assuntos que ele
investigava eram muito mais importantes
do que do que fazemos outros colegas
pronto como é que uma pessoa como dessas
outro muda ao longo da nossa vida pela
primeira vez que isso me aconteceu foi
quando Foi uma reunião dos especialistas
viola mas querem investigadores do mar é
ligeiramente diferente esses colega ou
nunca tinha ouvido falar da minha pessoa
e eu achava que era super onde tinha
ouvido falar mas não sabe o que é que eu
fazer
eu falei que eu também não sei o que é
que eles faziam que a maior parte dos ou
também não conhecia porque gosta eu era
um ator secundário da vida de na vida
deles o meus eram atores secundários na
minha vida do Qual é o seu protagonista
e o ego Aí lá teve o seu a sua a sua o
seu primeiro golpe e não sou o seu Ok
vamos ter um bocadinho mais um deles não
há nenhum professor que não diga que a
sua área tem especificidades e que é
muito importante e não sei mas isso é
quase sempre falso Ok ou quase sempre
limitada tá bem e portanto e muitas
vezes usa acesso às questões das cidades
para manter as coisas tal como estão e
como enfim como um poder conservador de
um sistema que é o mais familiar e que é
o mais familiar tão mais fácil tá bem e
eu compreendo perfeitamente a noção de
segurança que estudar todos professores
e alunos
e quando a pessoa tenta às vezes Inovar
às vezes/com resistência não só dos
colegas mas também pelo menos que me
dizem para não a professora nós temos
era apontamentos e exemplos de exames
com essa Nem é preciso ficar uma drive
alguns na nuvem que tem isso tudo a e
quando eu vou fazer coisas novas e ponto
onde faço coisas novas os outros que
sempre observamos isso Onde é que está
como é que a gente sabe como é que está
a fazer então eu enunciado A pois nos é
que não temos exemplo dos outros anos
pois não tem que temos que levar um
bocadinho e temos que procurar portanto
a para isso temos que olhar para os
currículos temos que orar porque senão
forma integrada Global a e como pessoas
estejam disponíveis para isso porque se
não eu vou achar que a minha disciplina
essencial que não é importante mas não é
essencial em biologia outros colegas vão
sarcástico no Brasil são também
Obviamente as coisas mais importantes do
universo a equipe criando uns currículos
mas
ou menos o menos de matéria do ponto de
vista formal que dá às pessoas a
oportunidade de explorar outras coisas
também não podemos a criar disciplinas
do curso de propósito processos
professores antigamente o que se fazia
na universidade podemos já começou era
procurava-se a identificava as quais
eram as necessidades do momento quais
eram as coisas importantes que toda a
gente tinha que receber a chamada de
carreras e depois vamos procurar pessoas
boas para dar aquelas matérias não
podemos estar agora a criar a deixar que
as pessoas crianças simples a sua medida
só porque sim porque senão vamos ter em
coisas positivas vamos ter que a
conteúdos que fazem porque não a naquele
momento naquele naquele na universidade
ninguém se capaz dar aquilo que não tem
que ir buscar não ou converter ou as
pessoas têm de se converter a outras
coisas temos tá todos abertos é isso eu
dou a minha disciplina de biologia de
diferenciação e desenvolvimento
um dos Estados Unidos a falei com meu
diretor departamento olhei para o curso
e o jeito certo Ninguém está a dar isto
como deve ser e o diretor que é uma
pessoa de fato de Torricelli pa Carvalho
era uma pessoa bastante aberta estas
coisas estão o João ninguém dá a você
então monte lá a sua disciplina e o
Monteiro
a brotar quando estamos a falar de
coisas que ligam disciplinas Eu gosto
muito de falar com outras pessoas e
fazer projetos que psicólogos ou médicos
com economistas sociólogos onde você
dinheiro imensa e mensagem gosto imenso
de fazer três vezes a liga em várias
coisas que são os mais enriquecedoras e
os mais importantes para transformarmos
a nossa sociedade nós os biólogos e
bioquímicos não temos que ser tudo o que
dizem um médico o jurista o historiador
um psicólogo ou ícones estão Engenheiro
não tem que entender tudo o que eles
dizem mas temos que ser capazes de falar
entender um menino e colaboração na
mente sempre que eles paternalistas ou
maternalista de quem está acima ou
abaixo de uma coisa qualquer ou qual que
é melhor melhor não é não somos todos
isso implica uma aprendizagem mútua
é isso interdisciplinar e
multidisciplinar não podem ser só
palavras que se usam porque fica muito
bem mas depois não ser concretizado é
nesta concretização que eu acho que nós
falhamos falhamos falhamos um carro na
verdade e já volto a repetir a muitos
pessoa se calhar até no entanto não
estão nada interessados nisto Ok nada a
barriga ótimo Ok perceber lamento mas
por cento mas se calhar Estão
interessados em coisas mais diferentes
alguns alunos e algumas pessoas se
calhar o suficiente para começar
estivemos muita gente juntas junto e que
consiga pensar de forma diferente mas
integrada as seremos mais humanos temos
que fazer de vez em quando coisas que
nos assustem O que é que os times na
nossa zona de conforto que nos tirem nas
nossas caixas que nos tirem papá ahh que
nos façam pensar um bocado diferente eu
lembro da primeira vez que estive que
fui falar com o médico e com Engenheiros
médicos até que eu gostaria de uma
linguagem muito próxima de viu
O que é mas não é bem o Rui senhor
quando a primeira vez que eu falei com
esse meus colegas estavam até muita
graça pensava que estava aqui no Star
Trek a tentar comer carne te ligou e eu
não falo com ele não não estávamos a
conseguir comunicar mas depois lá fomos
encontrando os pontos de contacto e lá
fomos evoluindo nas nossas nas nossas
colaborações isso explicações tem que
ser feita a gente tem que estar abertos
a essas dificuldades aos 40 anos a eu
fiz uma sabática no estado da Califórnia
em São Francisco fui para fora e vou ali
fora a trabalhar em laboratório pela
primeira vez em muitos anos eu tinha
vindo para Portugal em
há dez anos antes e desde tinha estado a
orientar alunos no laboratório não tinha
estado propriamente no laboratório e eu
a fazer a experiência mas achei que
precisava de aprender coisas sobre as
novas tecnologias que estavam emergir e
ver se faz eu não tinha com Taquinho no
contato de conquista e aí tive que ir
para o laboratório era de longe a pessoa
mais velha que ela estava no laboratório
e tive que receber treino e instruções
de Miúdos tinham vinte e poucos anos
Mike Jéssica muito simpáticos a que o
chamavam sozinho achavam que eu era um
copo maluco cantava assim a meter-se na
em experiências novas tecnologias que
não recebi nada as novas tecnologias ele
nem sequer sabia ligar os aparelhos
porque eram coisas que eu nunca tinha
trabalhar aí todo obviamente que eu tive
que
e agradeceram Mike a Jéssica e
obsessores que não foi fácil porque eu
gostava que eu sabe mas eu achava que o
pior é que eu não sabia que mais que
eles e é mais graduado mas ele é que
sabiam como é que funcionava a casa para
eles como é que faziam aquelas
experiências eu não esquece não não
sabia tanto remédio que viveu a questão
é a monte de conhecimentos que nós
estamos agora aplicar Quando surgiram
quando estamos a investigar ao não tenho
aplicação nenhuma aplicação não não é
necessariamente uma coisa imediata e a
universidade não pode abordar não pode
ser um prestador de serviços só também
pode prestar serviço e deve mas não pode
ser só até porque ponta fazemos isso
estamos a preparar-nos com o futuro Pode
não estar lá quando for quando chegasse
quando tu tá chegar prever o futuro é
sempre muito complicado e é muito
importante perceber que ok a sociedade o
mercado de trabalho as empresas podem
preci
em certos tipos de conhecimentos e eles
da deve estar disponível para colaborar
nisso mas a investigação básica aquela
aquela tal que não tem aplicação
imediata só Universidade que possa fazer
até a impressão e importante que alguém
faça porque daqui a nada a coisas que
poderão ter aplicação daqui a dez anos
conhecimento nós não estamos a ver
depois não se fazem e não conseguimos
Inovar e limitamos a nossa autonomia e
prendemos muito a uma rede de ar
o quanto temos que colaborar comum Sim
claro mas não podemos ser subservientes
ao mundo que o nosso objetivo é também
mal e isso é um problema que existe que
eu estou a par que existe aí que tenho
andado a tentar mudar ao longo dos anos
é o ensino está focado em quantificações
expectativas constante e gratificações
em meados o exame aos seus trabalhos
Vale y e seu entregar um trabalho sobre
imaginemos que eu tenho que entregar um
trabalho a raça que ele tiver jeito a
espero positiva é uma coisa que eu os
meus alunos que têm às vezes negativas
nos traz ficou muito espantado
perfuravam depois estava ter entregar o
trabalho para ter em Deco quando é que
isto acontece na vida real na vida real
nós estamos constantemente a dar notas
uns aos outros
o entre "notas estamos sempre e não não
damos é sinceramente nem dá nem dá a ver
nem de 1 a 5 e se o peso variando temos
sempre avaliar não temos sempre avaliar
outras pessoas e ser avaliados por
outras pessoas isso é uma coisa natural
e não e não estamos sempre para Qual é a
escala Qual é a escala que as pessoas
estão atualizar e quanto é que elas são
utilizados por diferentes diferentes
aspectos da avaliação que estão a fazer
do nosso do nosso da nossa pessoa da
nossa da nossa atividade e pronto temos
que me largar um bocadinho este
espartilho ele vendas da primária é
muito difícil além de complexidade
integração são dois conceitos que temos
de trabalhar ao longo da formação sempre
há também as noções aliás notas quando
aparecem crise de saúde pública outros
outros exemplos noções de incerteza é
preciso perceber que nós não controlamos
tudo e não sabemos tudo as pessoas
e sabendo tudo sempre a São ao som de
Cardoso São ignorantes só que não sabe o
que é e eu não sou um fracasso que é
extraordinariamente importante nós temos
que ser capazes no ensino em vez das
suas narrativas as éticas que funcionam
sempre porque são desenhadas para
funcionar sempre temos também dizer que
as pessoas coisas falham isso não tem
mal nenhum não re culpa não é de ninguém
hoje nós podemos fazer uma experiência o
melhor alinhado o melhor possível e às
vezes falha as vezes não funciona às
vezes não conseguimos descobrir aquilo
que estamos à espera Mas aprendemos
coisas aprendendo a fazer melhor da
próxima vez quando eu falo em fracasso é
no sentido de Samuel Beckett uma
situação que eu gosto muito de Israel
ser lã Peter trabalhamos da próximos até
podemos falar outra vez mas poderemos
melhor teremos mais um são dos problemas
tivemos E aprendemos
o e tornamos melhores pessoas e assumir
é se essa noção essa dimensão de
falhanço faz-nos crescer Ok mostra uma
pessoa que nunca falhou e eu mostro uma
pessoa que ou é mentirosa ou é muito
pouco interessante muito pouquinho
voadora e muito pouco a rolante para o
ir para a evolução da das piscinas
Eu amo e depois foram tenho medo de
cometer erros eu cometi ML na minha na
minha vida obrigado a todos e felicidade
E aí
[Aplausos]